okay so last time i did a tick tock
in the car seem to
just piss some people off
kylie jenner's addressing backlash over
her recent tick tock video and you can
say she's not crying over spilled milk
it seemed to oh it looks like i'm
lactating so i was thinking we can start
a series called kylie in the car i love
it here's the back story earlier this
month the beauty mogul clapped back at
tiktok user plastic chandler after he
criticized kylie for how she filmed this
video okay this is better i'm just in my
car
i just dropped four new lip lash shades
this is for the girls that love
the look of a matte lip i just think
it's like
interesting because it's like you're a
billionaire girl like why are you
reviewing lip kits in your car when you
live in a multi-million dollar home like
you did not just go to the store and
pick that up well that video caught
kylie's attention and she called them
out in the comments writing it's really
not that deep or calculated this video
took me five minutes to make and yes i
still drive and do normal things and
kylie she's now doubling down
okay so last time i did a tick tock
in the car
it seemed to oh it looks like i'm
lactating yeah it seemed to
just piss some people off
i think some people thought it was like
fake or that
i really don't drive myself which is
just silly um
so i was thinking we can start a series
called kylie in the car
yep the reality star is turning that
little social shake up into a whole new
series for the first official episode i
will be
trying on
this beautiful red it's like orangey red
from the chris collection wow
chris
jenner
you killed it with this
am going to go
maybe change my shirt now
kylie isn't the only family member
dealing with some controversy her big
sis kourtney kardashian is too i'm just
like living life and
whatever happens happens and what
happened is court was named a brand
ambassador for a popular fast fashion
brand the fact that it was all about
sustainability and about having these
conversations and using our resources i
think that that was so interesting to me
quartz doing two sustainability driven
collections and documenting her
experience on social media i am so
excited to share everything that i've
been learning on this journey with the
world and just trying to like broaden
the conversation and hopefully make a
difference
but some critics online aren't here for
it calling the entire collab a big
contradiction court addressed the
backlash on instagram with a lengthy
post writing i went back and forth about
doing this collection because the first
thing i think about when i hear the
words fast fashion is that it's bad for
our planet the court adds she hopes
she's making a change and raising
awareness quote i certainly don't have
all the answers but for someone who has
done a fast fashion line collaboration
in the past which didn't get backlash
because i was not calling attention to
trying to make better changes i feel
proud about doing it with intention and
purpose
[Music]
you